welcome back to the real rejects i'm greg alba i'm
john humphrey we're going to watch today from new
rock stars obi-wan kenobi trailer easter eggs
and breakdown i watched this trailer like four
more times last night so many little clues we
missed eric's not pointing them all out for us
i already know them all figured all that
myself no this will be just for me then
i will be enlightened by them leave a like
people new rock stars is the bomb let's do this
welcome back to new rockstars i'm
eric voss and this is a breakdown
of the trailer for obi-wan kenobi or should i say
because duel of the bates is back
in our ears and all of the ghosts
of obi-wan's past are back to haunt
him as he strives to protect a young
luke skywalker ahead of his rematch with
darth vader i loved this trailer and i'm
gonna break it down frame by frame because
it is filled with awesome star wars easter
eggs it just includes subtle details that
you just might have overlooked so let's go
the fight is done
we lost the trailer opens with
anakin skywalker's favorite stuff
sand it coarsely and roughly
and irritatingly gets everywhere
under the twin sons of tatooine in
the music there's how they are magical
the great john williams is returning
to the music for this series and this
riff is played on a celeste which john
williams loves to muse like in his series
oh is that what that is that is beautiful
if you remember the opening shot of the
last jedi teaser there's a little riff there yes
i just had this image in my head of john williams
going by his piano i'm going i need something new
actually the music in the first section of this
trailer is john williams theme from revenge
of the sith called the battle of the heroes just
showing how after all these years obi-wan is still
haunted by the memory of his friend's
betrayal and what he had to do to him
obi-wan writes an eop a tattooing
animal first scene in phantom menace
yes yes
but also the steed obi-wan was seen
in the final scene of revenge of the sith this
series was much more difficult years later in the
year nine bby that's nine years before the events
of a new hope this is the middle period when
obi-wan an exile under the alias of ben kenobi
keeps a watchful eye over young luke skywalker
keeping him hidden from the empire as a farm boy
living with his uncle owen and his aunt peru he's
supposed to age in just like 10 years into alec
mcginnis yep it's going to be a rough life on
tattoo that is insane yeah yeah he's gotta get all
ancient by then now various other star wars titles
over the years have touched on obi-wan's time
during this period saving young luke's life at
various points as owen would warn him to stay away
and then actually at one point saving owen from
black personality and that wookie who just showed
up in bubba bed giving bk that scar that we saw
in his head and then at another point later than
the show when lucas 12 he saved him from a crate
dragon actually see obi-wan walking into town and
slicing off a piece of meat this actually might
be a slab of crate dragon meat from one that he
had butchered obi-wan laments the fight is done
we lost yeah you'll notice this voice sounds a bit
echoey here as if he might be speaking these words
while in a meditative state communicating perhaps
with yoda or maybe with the ghost of qui-gon
yoda told obi-wan that he would teach
him how to reconnect with the ghost of
his old master an old friend has learned
the path to immortality your old master
yes how to commune with him i will teach you so
let us all pray liam neeson returns to the series
to impart this very particular set of skills
moving on well in the club wars he does at
one point reconnect with qui-gon what is
that planet called that fail what a mortise
dammit damn it all in hell i'm done with this you
are the star wars expert yeah that's what i know
failure fake nerd and i do think there was
actually a deleted scene that you could see
of yoda communing with qui-gon that
might be the exact clip on youtube
yoda commuting so obi-wan watches over
the lars homestead looking just as it did
in a new hope with owen and brew even wearing
pretty much the same outfits that they wore in
that first film actually this is dark but
they are standing in the same exact spot
where luke will later find their coordinates
oh my goodness no torch the home meanwhile 10
year old luke plays as a pilot it looks like he's
actually wearing pod racing goggles and the way he
pantomimes operating the controls and leans just
looks so much like young anakin piloting during
that pod race and right as obi-wan pushes in on
luke the moment he zooms in on him john williams
battle of the heroes theme transitions
so smoothly into the classic force theme
stay hidden let's move on best songs
choir vocals lucasfilm got dusted
to hunting jedi oh baby what a needle drop
john williams doula the fates is of
course best known from phantom menace
but the music was always bigger than just
darth maul's theme because it's really
come back throughout star wars titles or the
lyrics of the song john williams translated
an old welsh poem called battle of the trees
into the sanskrit language he wanted to frame
this duel as a kind of pagan religious ceremony
almost like the spirits of both sides of this
conflict the jedi and the sith shrieking like
a greek chorus egging on their mortal champions
and that's today he's still being waged
now as obi-wan faces darth vader once more
as he faces the inquisitors and maybe also faces
a rematch with maul because this is set one year
after the events of soloist star wars story
which established maul as the powerful head
of the crimson dawn crime organization now in star
wars rebels which is several years after this maul
will eventually track down obi-wan to tatooine
but this is something he would not yet know
at this point of this show so that rematch would
not go down on tatooine but we do see obi-wan go
off world in this trailer either way maul could
simply cameo in some other scene that would set
him upon his revenge quest in rebels at least
give sam witwer one more chance to reprise this
is so good speeds across this ocean planet towards
this fortress this is the ocean moon of ner and
this is the fortress inquisitorious so let's talk
about the inquisitors originally the jedi hunters
from the 1987 role-playing game inquisitors were
introduced in rebels explored further in the 2015
darth vader comics and in the jedi fallen order
game they are a squad of four sensitive beings
trained by darth vader to hunt down jedi survivors
of order 66. they're led by the grand inquisitor
voiced in rebels by jason isaacs and played here
by rupert friend turned rupert foe this is the one
using the mummified remains of the jedi master
luminara unduli the grand inquisitor dies at
the end of that season there are some
things far more frightening than death
but he was later revealed to be one of those jedi
guards in clone wars who helped arrest ahsoka tano
when she was falsely accused of bombing the jedi
temple and then later he helped arrest the true
culprit barissafi but from that experience
he learned the flaws in the jedi orthodoxy
and that's what opened him up to be corrupted by
palpatine and it would suggest palpatine did that
to help expedite the fall of the jedi temple i
just want to say really quick every time there's
an adaptation from an animated character into
live action there's backlash so the first thing
i saw was backlash for grand inquisitor it's
going to always look a little different guys
it's not something we need to throw i always think
what would it look like if we went in reverse can
you imagine if count dooku looked like how we did
in clone wars it would look super goofy you know
you you gotta readjust here when you're doing
it in the actual live action humanoid form it's
going to look different it's gonna have to fit the
aesthetic of the series as well now the fortress
inquisitorius is a secret location after the
inquisitors were forced to relocate from coruscant
so that now they're really off the books
the moon of ner is actually very close to
mustafar where vader's castle now stands
their shuttles which we've seen in concept
art have a two-pronged tip that matches the
two-pronged tower of vader's castle oh cool
the water fortress in the game fall in order and
that game reveals the backstory of the inquisitor
named the second sister trilla suduri former
padawan to sir agenda the second sister goes
on to fight calcus and in defeat nearly forgives
her from her master but is executed by darth vader
other inquisitors include the fifth brother and
the seventh sister from season two of rebels who
tried to kill kanan jairus and ezra bridger and
an arc that also introduces the eighth brother
an inquisitor who'd been trying to track down
maul all three of these inquisitors end up killed
there was also the sixth brother who had tried to
kill ahsoka tano but ahsoka defeated him taking
his blades kyber crystals and purifying them white
which is why in rebels animated lauren season two
ahsoka has those twin white lightsabers cool
all that inquisitor all just great however how
baller of a move would it be if they actually got
calculus to be in this show it would line up they
already designed calcus to be in the likeness of
cameron monahan so adapting him into live action
you probably wouldn't hear all those complaints so
weird now what's wrong with this guy though people
find a way to complain about it now if you look
closely on the fortress landing pad that looks
like a lambo class shuttle there that's the same
kind of [ __ ] vader and other imperial vips
used for transportation so vader may be present
here checking in on to the next clip patience
jedi cannot help what they are their compassion
leaves a trail so the grand inquisitor faces down
what looks like a cantina barkeep on tatooine his
armor looks as it doesn't rebels though here it
has a badge that he did not have before maybe he's
a special designation he gets from the emperor
that he loses after his failures on this series
now later in the trailer the inquisitor riva a
major character who we're going to be following
on the show played by moses ingram stops a runner
dead in his tracks in the same cantina and in this
shot you can see riva in the background on the
right oh and then on the left the inquisitor
with a wide head piece this is actually the fifth
brother from rebels now in live action played by
son fast in the furious films i had no idea that's
oh justice that's so cool that he gets to do this
oh yeah that's great just that's justice for
han this is how we get asian people finally in
star wars undertones i'm just kidding i've had
several asian characters already yeah we've had
enough aging care we're done then we see a skiff
on tatooine transporting it looks like workers
including our man ben kenobi just blending in
i love how it puffs out black smoke just making
this look like a really cheap polluting piece of
hardware meanwhile we hear the grand inquisitor
lecturing the key to hunting jedi is patience i
love it help what they are their compassion leaves
a trail you know what he's kind of like is hans
landa from inglorious bastards that's what the
speech sort of made me reminisce on because this
glass that delicious blue milk now i know to a lot
of you that sounded like the voice of palpatine
but according to closed captioning on the trailer
it was actually the grand inquisitor but it's
a really interesting perspective from a former
jedi raised in the jedi temple now patronizing the
jedi as a cult-like mental disorder george lucas
did originally conceive the empire as space nazis
and hear the grand inquisitor's assessment see
i don't see sort of ss of the empire then inside
the lower subaquatic levels of the fortress
inquisitorius riva meets with the fifth brother
and another inquisitor with these tendrils both
have on their backs the ringed double-bladed
sabers carried by all inquisitors which allow
them to rotate the blades like a helicopter rotor
and you'll notice one of these chairs has a tall
two-pronged seat back matching both their ships
and vader's castle so this may be vader's chair a
nice table or the chair of the grand inquisitor
with that grand inquisitor trying to embody
vader's aesthetic then on tatooine someone
is suspended on display perhaps the fugitive
that riva chases down looking like a message
to the locals not to harbor jedi christians
i think they'd be a bit dark for star wars i
wonder if this guy is actually being forced
choked up over the ground and left to suffocate
among these bystanders is joel edgerton returning
as owen lars sweating like a gumpton mustapar
now it seemed at first like these acquitters
might be on tattooing looking for kenobi himself
but i don't know if they got that close i don't
know if pokemon would have been able to live for
another nine years after this rather i think there
is another force-sensitive fugitive who fled the
tatooine and just got too close to obi-wan and
this guy that goddamn planet he would not be able
to help else risk his exposure and endangered luke
who is another force sensitive kid the inquisitors
would probably target so perhaps while chasing
this random jedi riva then senses another presence
on this planet that forces obi-wan to lead her
off world and try to throw yeah that makes a
lot of sense that's a really good plot there
he cannot help it
where is he okay here we see riva on the new
planet named daiyu described by the writer of this
series as a hong kong-like setting with graffiti
written nightlife the neon orabesh beside riva
translates to er and then to her left as she looks
out letter spelling out milk kind of like old man
luke they love the lactate here the inquisitor
shuttle lands on tatooine and then a shot of
imperial officer played by indira varma aka elaria
sand from game of thrones that's where she's
from you can tell by her badge red red red blue
she is the rank of captain in the imperial navy
then that female inquisitor interrogates a lineup
on the daiyu street you can see an orbish sign in
the background translating to haas market and
as she walks right the last suspect on the end
is a large fur covered fella that we cut
away from quickly a wookie perhaps or an ewok
there's a smuggler then we see this quick shot
of a new droid letters on his chest looking like
they translate to ned i'm wondering if this could
be camille nanjiani's character which would keep
with the recent star wars tradition of comedians
yeah yeah yeah yeah bridge matt barry richard iot
alan tudyk let's not forget bill hader did
bb-8 yes he did let's not forget most iconic
let's not forget and richard pryor was r2d2
correct then the grand inquisitor fans his
lightsaber never breaking eye contact now
this bald dude does look a bit like the same
head shape as tamar morrison aka boba fett
aka every clone and clone trooper making me
wonder if this could be a runaway clone trooper
after order that would be cool to do
and i only bring this up because there
is another shot in this trailer showing
the backside of some really banged up
looking stormtrooper armor a little
too scratched for stormtrooper armor
would this be the clone trooper armor of rex could
rex be in this show i mean i know he wouldn't die
here because rex survived that would be so cool
screen time to make up for those two episodes
of the boba fett series i would absolutely
adore that there are some clones who end up
not being bad there's a guy named gregor hey
this is your guy that's my guy he's your guy
his name reminds me of someone but if you brought
rex in there and rex was in bad batch so clearly
they want to keep his presence alive and he's like
that clone outside of boba fett who intersects
throughout the series from club wars to bad batch
rebels and now to come into live action i think
that would be a really cool call or or cody here
the fifth brother leads a squad of stormtroopers
on daiyu and yup i translated all the orabesh on
the far right the last letters are e-t maybe the
last letters of the word market and then the blue
sign at the top of frame i think spells out the
same thing as the other blue sign in frame gungan
snacks and then on the right side we see some pink
letters with the green border also the same word
repeated with the orange letters in green border
both spelling out the word market and then
on the far right in orange once again milk
yeah i dream about that space these look a lot
like the pod used by yoda in revenge of the sith
to escape to dagobah at the moment he and obi-wan
separate to their respective exiles which tells
us that we may see flashbacks of the sith and
flashbacks to the clone wars era then we see
a black major hand touching a symbol chalked on
a wall this is the sigil of the jedi order the
saber flanked by the wings this actually may be
riva finding a jedi hiding place maybe the jedi
have used these markings to signal to each other
and to keep the hope alive then in an alley reeva
stares down a gunman's helicopter zobie one not
wanting to out himself yet by using his lightsaber
instead opting for the blaster so uncivilized i
love how the backlighting casts a long shadow in
front of a riva which gives her just as fearsome
edge but also suggests that her opponent will have
the light in his eyes for this duel then we see
a quick rooftop shootout that looks like obi-wan
engaging with some blasters coming from multiple
different directions i do like the detail of the
laundry being hung up to dry now they said they
based daiyu on hong kong and fun fact at mission
possible 3 j.j abrams actually had to digitally
remove shots of hanging laundry in shanghai
because local film distributors didn't want
shanghai to look poor but interesting deborah chow
leaves the laundry in then an overhead shot shows
a vent releasing these green birds i'm not really
sure but the best-known green bird in star wars
is mori the female convoy who befriended ahsoka
tano with a spiritual connection to the daughter
the mystical deity of mortis it is called mortis
but until now i don't think we've seen
a whole flock of these still i would
love for ahsoka tano to cameo in the series
since presumably obi-wan will have to leave
some babysitter looking after luke when he
leaves tatooine and it would give a bit more
context to ahsoka and luke's moments in the
book of boba fett then again rosario dawson
would be having to play an ahsoka 20 years
younger than when we've seen her before
i don't know how that would work so on
to the last clip get ashley eckstein back
okay after a close-up of obi-wan we get the series
title which if you look closely snuck in the shape
of obi-wan's lightsaber on that eye then we
hear the iconic breathing of darth vader and
we know hayden christensen is coming back in the
series to have an epic rematch with obi-wan kenobi
it's super exciting especially because if you
listen closely they use a specific music sting
this is john williams anakin's dark deeds track
for our revenge of the sith right after anakin
slaughtered the separatists leaders on moostabar
and bitterly stared into the lava and the flames
a tear rolling down his cheek a real tear not
a digital one and i love that they remind us
of this moment because for me whenever i
rewatch revenge of the sith this right here
was hayden christensen's darkest performance
just simply his silent glower his inner torment
there is a reason hayden was brought back for
the series because think about it if they just
wanted vader they could have brought back the
team they used for rogue one james earl jones
doing the voiceover men doing the performance
no they needed hayden christensen because
it's not just darth vader with the mask that
we're returning to it is the grief-stricken
rage-filled human underneath that mask so
this john williams light motif is a promise
that we will see this face again whether it's
invader's breathing apparatus or a close-up under
the mask the scarred face or maybe a different
form all together projected in astral form
wow these eyes once more lastly you gotta love
that blue lightsaber cutting in to form the disney
plus logo just between this and the moon night
leap in the moonlight trailer this is essentially
the house of mouse's new tinker bell swoosh over
the castle and i'm digging it also check out our
great merch options at new rockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at each
box follow new rockstars subscribe to rockstars
for more announcements of everything you love
all right thanks for watching and oh i
forgot to say hello there so um goodbye
there it's gonna get really annoying for people
when it does these number one videos a whole
bunch of hello there's that's all you're gonna
hear for the next several months hello there
and we're gonna be part of it too right part of
the pro subscribe to new rock stars leave a like
and hey we'll catch you all soon can't wait to
start reacting to the series it looks beautiful